bonjour bastien oui merci d'être bon en
direct sur arte france a alors le 7
janvier une alerte a donc été lancée par
le gestionnaire du réseau électrique
français
quant à de possibles coupures
électriques la faute c'est le froid
finalement la france n'a pas eu à subir
de coupure mais est-ce que c'est pas
sérieux avec avertissement pardon pour
cet hiver
oui edf avait même lancé une campagne
mais ton pull pour inviter les français
à baisser leur consommation et notamment
la température de leur chauffage
vous avez raison si on s'en tient au
discours de la ministre de la transition
écologique
barbara pompili en novembre dernier en
cas de vague de froid des coupures
d'électricité temporaire est localisée
ne sont pas à exclure
en sachant que le 8 janvier alors que
les températures étaient hivernal mais
pas extrêmes la france a dû obliger
certains sites industriels à interrompre
leur consommation
c'est quelque chose de prévu par leur
contrat avec carter mais en passer par
là en 2021 cela peut interroger et
inquiété alors bastien vous évoquez la
ministre barbara pompili pour l une des
causes de cette tension sur les réseaux
serait la trop forte dépendance de la
france au nucléaire
car une partie de nos réacteurs ont des
retards de maintenance à cause du coc
vie de 19
oui les écologistes et barbara pompe il
y explique qu'il faut justement
diversifier la production électrique en
installant plus d'éoliennes mais les
physiciens que nous avons rencontrés se
moque du raisonnement pour eux le coït
19 a bon dos et conteste les choix
stratégiques de la france
il cible notamment la fermeture de la
centrale de fessenheim en 2020 alors
qu'elle était jugée comme sûre par
l'autorité indépendante l'asn
cela fait deux réacteurs nucléaires de
900 mégawatts chacun au moins sur le
réseau la france a aussi décidé de
fermer depuis plusieurs années des
centrales thermiques avec cette idée les
éoliennes et les panneaux
photovoltaïques peuvent remplacer les
énergies pilotable sauf que ces énergies
renouvelables sont intermittentes
c'est à dire qu'elles ont besoin de
conditions météo spécifique pour
fonctionner or on constate le 8 janvier
de cette journée tendue sur le réseau
que l'éolien ne fonctionnaient quasiment
pas faute de vent c'est nucléaire qui a
globalement assuré la production malgré
les opérations de maintenance et donc
plus on mise sur les énergies
renouvelables éolienne et solaire
plus on risque d'avoir ce genre de
problème sur le réseau disons que depuis
septembre on réactive des centrales à
charbon car ni l'éolien ni le
photovoltaïque n'arrive à pallier les
fermetures des centrales pilotable on
est également obligé d'importer de
l'électricité comme au matin du 8
janvier à des pays voisins comme
l'allemagne de l'électricité importée
souvent carbonées donc émettrices de co2
car elle est issue du gaz ou du charbon
ceux qui s'intéressent à la question
énergétique qu'on a interrogés
avertissent les énergies intermittentes
doit venir en soutien des pilotable
comme le nucléaire et non les remplacer
or actuellement l'orientation prise par
le gouvernement est bel et bien de
réduire le nucléaire une énergie bas
carbone dans le mix énergétique au
profit des éoliennes
pour conclure je rappelle que le dernier
gros incident blackout date de 1978 cela
avait alors conduit la france à relancer
le programme électronucléaire
merci beaucoup bassa'a gouly je le
rappelle on peut vous lire sur le site
rtl france point tv et